a Maryland real-estate company had an
extraordinary surprise for employees at
this year's holiday party those red
envelopes I'll say revealed that the st.
John properties gave its workers ten
million dollars to share for the bonus
that means every single one of them got
a bonus from maintenance workers to
receptionist to vice presidents so the
average award was fifty thousand dollars
the lowest award was a hundred dollars
the highest to listen to this was two
hundred and seventy thousand dollars
based on how long they had been working
at the company the bonus was for meeting
a massive expansion goal some of the
workers say they're going to use the
money to pay off the mortgages of their
children's education others are going on
dream vacation and we should give a
shout-out in special mommy hook to this
boss his name is Lawrence make rants I
hope I said it correctly he says that so
they flew all they've got eight
different branches who everybody all the
out-of-state employees I know all the
airfare you're not leaving by car but I
like what he said he's the captain of
the ship but his employees make that
ship run which i think is only good
listen I'd love to see more employers I
do Viacom CBS to their credit everybody
did your we'd you don't have to defend
them it's no I was saying they're doing
something nice do we each get two paid
vacation days that we weren't planning
okay that's very nice I think that's
very nice good it's not a thing a bonus
of 207 but I think I think two paid
vacation is very nice